as you are moving around between apps
you probably notice that from a user
perspective Android doesn't announce
changes in app state it doesn't announce
that it slowing memory all ask users to
close apps to free up resources in fact
it does everything it can to make the
resource limitations of the device
invisible to the user that means keeping
the foreground app running smoothly and
switching between apps seamless and that
means killing apps in the background
there does that if it needs their
resources to make sure that the
foreground apps can continue to run so
we know that as soon as your app isn't
visible its life time is as perilous as
that of a stark at the red wedding
likely to die without notice but ready
to return from the dead that tells us
some very important things about how our
apps should behave to be good citizens
and provide a great user experience from
a system perspective on pause and on
stop for signals that our app may be
killed imminently so we need to clean up
any resources that need an orderly
teardown such as closing any open
connections or sockets